- So I hear you love Nashville,
you love stopping in Nashville.
- I'm obsessed with Nashville,
I'm gonna be on Nashville on the tour,
I love going to Nashville
because of the vintage stores,
they have the best vintage shopping.
But I think I might stop doing it 'cause
last time I went, I got this
awesome denim jacket, it had all these,
patches on it and pins and I wore
it all the time on Instagram like,
I have a horse and you
know, I ride my horse
in this jacket and I loved it so much and
I got this DM one day, from this guy
who was like "Hey, my ex got mad at me
"and sold a bunch of my
stuff to a vintage store."
(audience gasping and laughing)
I think you have--
- First of all, that's awesome!
- I know! (laughing)
- How have I not thought of that?
(audience laughing and applauding)
That is amazing, you're trashing
their stuff plus making profit!
- Totally!
This woman is an entrepreneur
and she sounds awesome and,
so he said, "Can I have it back?"
and I was like, "Yeah I guess."
so I sent it back to him.
- Did you tell him, "For
this amount of money"?
- I know!
- "Because I bought it, sorry
she's a turd" but, yeah.
- So that, and then the
other thing about going to the south,
is that I'm still trying
to figure out like, what
everything means and you can probably
help me with the southern
colloquialisms?
- Ah, yes.
- What does "Bless your heart" mean?
- Mmm.
- Does it, it means you're stupid!
- Well, it there's,
- Right?
- There's like, it depends on the tone,
and who you're saying it to.
- Okay, so when I go to the south,
they'll ask me where
I'm from and I'm like,
"I live in L.A.", and they're like,
"Bless your heart."
- "Bless your heart."
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
Yep!
Or it's like, you know
- What does that mean?
- Its, well it's not a
compliment sometimes.
(Whitney and audience laughing)
It's a southerner's
way of, of being shady.
- Yes! (laughs)
- But doesn't it sound nice, it's like,
it's like British people cursing you out.
- That's so true!
- You know, it's nice!
It's like, you know it's
rude but I like it, yeah.
- And then I learned the hard way that
when a woman, in the south says she's
"Fixin' to pitch a fit."
- I'm fixin' to pitch a fit, yeah.
- Get out of there, get out of there.
- Yep, and grab anything that belongs
to you, 'cause she'll sell it too.
(audience laughing)
A southern woman, no, she's smart.